l'inventeur de la torture du gibet du
but chez les chats fouda chaise
électrique du sabre du fusil des gaz
empoisonné par dessus tout de la justice
du devoir du patriotisme de tous les
autres mots en isme haas auquel ceux là
même qui serait assez intelligent pour
être plus humain se laisse convaincre
ils finissent par devenir les plus
destructeurs des destructeurs presque
tout ce que je jouais t16 culotté enfin
nous dans dans des genres différents ne
se soit par exemple nous le dessus au
moment où john mélo le diable et le bon
dieu j'ai eu des réactions
particulièrement d'année
c'est que m'est arrivé de constater que
un certain public qui vient trouvera
favet le mécontent de service si on peut
dire n'attendent pas la réponse
il se branche sur ce que vient de dire
le personnage dans le développement du
mythe avait pas lieu de dire des choses
très contre l'église mais il y avait la
réponse immédiate
il n'attendait pas la réponse alors
j'étais obligé une fois ou de m'arrêter
déduire une seconde second monsieur ça
reprend encore de moi vous dire
moi je vive véritablement vers les
personnages je ne tire pas les
personnages à moi je pense que le public
se rend compte c'est d'entrer dans un
autre pont et avec d'autres réflexes et
j'ai ce que certains rendent compte au
moins
enfin je crois que le public est assis
bon juge décent qui ont fait l'effort de
siari un personal pas connu beaucoup de
rôles d'amitié moi je suis pas trop du
personnage était d'avoir des amis pour
le moment du show très scripté je ne
sais quoi je ne saurais pas l'exprimer
devant un public
ou alors avec certaines ou une
désinvolture ou une sensibilité très peu
apparente